[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
oh
tu as vu qu'ils viennent juste pour toi
tablier oui j'ai le thème la ville il a
mieux que je vais pas si vous avez vu
mais le tablier déchirait de bobby les
déchirures moisan
qui se soucie trou de vent mais il ya
quelque chose qui a bercé le tabbee ça
serait donc pas une vraie fille
il doit tu as failli partir avec une
fille alors une de vos j'ai invité la
semaine dernière encore le but le match
le mouvement je peux en vendre l'équipe
uriner elle voulait qu'il ait pu un peu
il ya partie de la culture
j'ai trouvé c'est un peu tôt quand même
pour aller chez nantis alors on attend
un peu ouais elle voulait tomber chez
elle oui
je suis fériés
et si j'étais hugo il proposait donc en
fait beaucoup trop tôt
[Musique]
oui bonsoir oui bonsoir c'est thierry
roland et al azhar mes yeux au quatrième
étage quatrième étage merci beaucoup de
vent nous arrive
[Musique]
4e étage vêtements pour hommes voilà
c'est
pas tous leurs titres phares d'antibes
avant car dans cette mettra droite
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir monsieur j'avais compris merci
beaucoup
ça lui a un ça va bon tu vois tu rien
non mes respects monsieur thierry grand
talent et vous savez très bien je donne
mon tour maintenant on n'a pas les
moyens celle ci donne pas de nom pas
encore mais ça va venir
bonsoir messieurs oui
sébastien bonsoir stéphane saint
sébastien
si toi on s'en fout
une paix que je t'ai pas vu ça depuis
autant en emporte le grand tu te
rappelles de la fin de l'émission ça te
dit rien christophe you should be wrong
way après l'émission que christophe
tiozzo prend avec son copain sous la
halle un coup de couteau ouais non non
pire son copain prend une balle dans la
tête il meurt le copain christophe deux
heures après l'émission
après ton émission ah non c'est pas le
truc où il s'était ouvert hier ça
c'était un autre plan que
je te signale que j'ai acheté le baby
boom oui alors je trouvais très bien
mais je voudrais qu'il me faudrait que
tu mettes un mot mais je te mettrai un
mot 1 alors comment je fais à thierry
pour un autre tu t'es là je te le nom
m'échappe je dépose ici ou alors ce que
tu fais tu donnes ainsi que je vois ton
frère pratiquement tous les jours c'est
pas vrai pour mathilde quelle horreur
pour matisse on se voit tous les soirs à
bon on te donne tu es tu voyais pas trop
mais pas trop quoi vous êtes fâchés ne
se font que je suis fâché c'est que il
est exactement le contraire de moi
pourquoi mais parce que tout ce que
j'aime ils aiment pas et moi tout ce
qu'il aime les femmes toi oui déjà au
départ bon en face à gérard bon je fais
abstraction chacun fait ce qu'il veut
avec ses jouets ouais ils se ressemblent
pas du tout non un jour me l'a présenté
le mieux c'est régine pascal régine le
connais depuis toujours et alors elle
lui dit exprès tu vois lui dit mehdi
dont entre thierry et toi qu'est ce
qu'elle est née alors elle lui dit mais
attends mais tire il a 9 ans de plus que
moi en bas le 10 10 dans charlevoix pour
c'est vrai c'est vrai
plutôt famille tient aux fruits mais je
suis en contact avec qui je suis tu veux
moi je suis né juste au moment où mon
père est ce que déjà huilé n'est non
plus tôt lui il est né juste au moment
où mon père est décédé parce que déjà
quand on fait le bouquin tout à fait
thierry tu m'as dit que tu as eu plus de
peine concernant les morts que les
cantons bien sûr père et bien sûr il n'a
pas connu son père louis pratiquement un
train très peu n'ont pratiquement pas
connu et moi je suis né en 37 lui en 40
il est parti à la guerre il est revenu
en 45 et en 46 il est mort de suites aux
carrières il le foot tout seul tous
courent c'est même pas dans quel sens ça
va il sait pas la différence
comment ça se passe sur m6 a très bien
géré on est sympa on
évolue un peu les boules quand même un
ton de tf1 et 25 25 ans m nos
associations j'ai eu les boules mais bon
si tu veux j'avais dépassé 65 ans
il y avait vomi toi qui est plutôt
habitué à vichy kazan non mais à voir le
côté un peu j'aime j'ai même vu des
déclarations de charles villeneuve qui a
dit si on voulait le garder on a regardé
énorme à lui lui il n'a pas été bien sûr
stats il a pas été n'y en a vraiment pas
été bien
est ce que t'as pas il sorte de manque
le le dimanche téléfoot
non je l'avais pas difficilement parce
que le téléfoot que je connaissais il
sera le plus que tu penses de celui-là
celui de villeneuve le gilardi moi
personnellement je n'aime pas vraiment
ou alors parce que je n'aime pas mais
parce que il ya mille ya plus de
reportages sur le championnat y attend
rien plus rien ils taxés il te passe en
vitesse accélérée le championnat de
france quand tu vois les maquis ils
courent comme des trente ans franchement
est ce que c'est normal tap tap une le
show mais bon c'est vrai que le
championnat de france il est pas
terrible le tapis
non
je oui bonsoir bonsoir
à tout de suite
m
je jure c'est très bon qu'est ce cas là
dedans
sinon c'est du caramel juste comme tu
sais comment on va l'appeler suis jamais
tué thierry roland
[Applaudissements]
longuet
voilà soir bonsoir
convient moi votre manteau
il vous plait voilà
et sans rien qui était debout
que 6e
oh
quelle surprise c'est du lourd comment
ça va recevoir ce nouveau monsieur guy
roux dans son jeu face à mathieu oui je
viens ou pour soir histoire messieurs
monsieur
bon ça va a détruit nos rangs parler de
téléphone de là c'est plus ce que
c'était quoi
moi je le regarde pas je regarde regarde
oui lorsque le dimanche matin je regarde
des matchs de jeunes
toute ma vie j'ai pratiquement jamais
regardé téléfoot de pixels matin parce
qu'avant j'avais entraînement le
lendemain de match décrassage - il y
avait des télés dans la dans les
vestiaires je regardais intellisense
côté sur canal aujourd'hui revoir le
guillou
non vraiment même avant l'heure et je
pouvais pas tu pouvais en 1960 à peu
près 1
il devient entraîneur joueur à auxerre
le comité directeur de l'époque ne veut
pas de lui sauf quelques noms importants
certes eh bien il fait sa carrière il
exige de faire l'équipe et à l'époque
avait très pâle équipe tout seul
il n'avait plus d'entraîneur c'était mon
club d'origine j'avais des gamins et
alors ils me disent bon ben si tu
reviens jouer chez nous il fallait que
je faisais un stage au centre du
commerce extérieur à paris dont il
viendra jouer chez nous si oui mais je
veux être entraîneur joueur de mettet
foot à 21 heures et demie cependant
traînait déjà contre en tant que donneur
moi je bombe impose ta candidature jean
une lettre six pages ils l'ont publiée
dans le livre la dette du centenaire où
j'explique tout toute la stratégie un
comprendrait la ferme qu'on abstraite
11h10 trucs et tous les piges demande
600 francs par mois ouais
c'est un gars car on y arrive il y avait
dix candidats y avait jean baratte il y
avait des anciens pros dans ce temps là
beaucoup qui était candidat pour être
entraîneur de l'équipe de dh est il bon
j'arrive je viens des boîtes coup tu
sors dehors j'attends une heure et demie
dans la cour puis viennent me chercher
joyeux vont le président cet égard nos
élus à l'unanimité on t'a choisi bien
ouais ok merci tout à la première
discussion combien de ballons il en
reste deux il y en a un qui crevait j'en
veux cinq nommés tfou
wallon comme ça et puis trois ou quatre
ans après il ya un ils étaient 11 le
comité directeur était à auxerre
ils étaient onze et y en a qu avait un
cancer alors je dis il le ramène chez
lui quoi les derniers jours et il dit
c'est gentil d'être venu parce que c'est
je pouvais pas partir sans dire j'ai
voté contre toi
moi je sais rien il s'appelait pas
populaire pap ont resserré le faire
papou je sais rien il m'arrivait je veux
dire les autres
c'est notre et quatre bouts voilà et
m'ont pris parce que j'étais le moins
cher qui êtes en dessous donc j'ai
commencé par la plus mauvaise vente du
monde la vente par le prix claire déjà
déjà à l'époque il ya une question de
d'économie forcément pour moi le ballon
c'est un truc magique parce que quand
j'étais gamin on bossait toutes les
vacances vingt gamins pour acheter un
bal ces pressions augmentent donc à
galon pour moi c'est magique donc aucun
ballon dans la tribune n'était pas on
n'en revenait pas j'envoyais des coastal
chercher toujours on sait pas fait
piquer en 40 ans du ballon et une faux
bond au paris saint germain
r toi les gars fin d'échauffement il
envoie deux ballons à leurs supporters
comme ça mon retour j'ai mis les
entraîneurs des cadets dans la tribune
du côté on s'échauffe ou pas j'en ai
piqué 4g seulement sept autres
tu étais avant centre de footballeur
puis de gamins louis gâtés avant centre
mais tu aurais pu faire carrière et a
refusé je crois que c'était limoges nom
ou tu as envie d'être footballeur
précieuse et moi ça
les deux miss était pas un vern et 6,6
pas mal bon et un verre qu'elle fait la
coupe du monde 58 et seasick été
champion de france avec reims et moi
intérêts vont tous les ans la petite
dette j'entre dans le ses efforts et
jeudi si je suis meilleur que je suis
une carrière si je suis pas meilleur que
fo se fasse autre chose et donc je fais
trois ans et afin de la transmettre
toutes les saq est forte partout les
moeurs femmes en moi joule et
internationale les bovins donc au bout
de trois ans alors jetez estimé parce
qu'en plus j'étais président des
étudiants la balle et l'unef ge est
estimé par le président par tout le
monde mais je jouais pas en peau est
alors je vais voir flamion je demande un
rendez vous avec kadhafi en pierre
flamion et judy alors répondez moi
franchement est ce que je peux faire un
pot de 1re division
- la flamme et on me dit ça va te faire
de la peine de la réponse est non
et c'est mieux de le dire il dit je veux
tu dois savoir pourquoi
il dit est trop lent trop lent trop lent
et rolande geste volant de course
j'avais une très bonne technique deux
pieds la tête poitrine tout mais trop
lent mais là bon j à l'offre joue unis
deuxième division tu te balades avec ta
technique tu est meilleur que 80% des
joueurs de d2 ça va moins vite tu peux
faire une très belle carrière de qui ça
m'intéresse pas
[Musique]
et
oui mon choix aux parents ce moment
si l'avenir mais moi j'ai le quatrième
étage vous placez
[Musique]
swing moiselle mon choix
je lui confiais moi voulons tous s'il
vous plaît
quand j'étais gamin je connaissais mieux
le foot aujourd'hui alors c'est mon
métier de raconter
demoiselle vous passez par la cuisine
[Musique]
après n'y a pas de jeux sur le foot à la
télé c'est pas bizarre oui c'est bizarre
et des mouvements à l'essai ils ont
on
nettoie une fois dehors
son vignoble oui fx à bonsoir madame
installé tirer
cécile ça va bien
quand ben d'arrêter de la joueur
formidable jouer dans le championnat de
france au stade français comment c'est
les mecs qui voulait pas qu'il m'a vu il
était musulman ouais dans ce temps-là
les shorts avec des poches il en
remettait des saucisses ans il prônait
aboud l'a
aidé à ben barek cette approche à plus
de 30 mètres du but je te frotte avec le
lard à ébène barras qui joue en retrait
il a quand même bien changé thierry 1 à
l'époque à l'époque du bouquin thierry
ne supportait pas beaucoup les les
filles qui commentait les matchs de
football et celle denis et communales et
sur m6 a pourtant elle avait fait un
ciseau retourné sur les changes dans
lequel je me rappelle de ta phrase et tu
as vu le football se commentent avec du
poil aux pattes non non mais ce qui a
c'est que j'ai eu deux expériences coup
sur coup sophie thalmann way qui a été
très bonne et mademoiselle qui est
excellente à nantes a changé d'avis j'ai
changé d'avis tracé parce que le parce
que le monde évolue parce que pascal
comment tu le rencontres et le bon
raymond c'est ms consultant c'est une
émission
café guy robert comeau et que vous aviez
fait prolongation sur tps au jus revoilà
donc on s'est rencontrés comme ça on
travaillait ensemble c'était un coup de
foudre tout de suite non non
non on travaille ensemble et ça c'est ça
c'est fait il devra régler un peu nos ou
quatre au patro enfin je le voyais venir
quand même battu l'assaut elles seront
toutes les finesses à
elles sont mal sur meilleur que nous
arrive et avec son gros sabots bien sûr
parce que monsieur avait quand même des
règles les jours du sériphile et non
celui que j'ai complètement oublié
alors est-ce que cdd des légendes ou pas
ils contrôlaient les le kilométrage des
voitures pour voir si les ses joueurs
n'étaient pas dans les boîtes de nuit
c'est au début parce que il cadenasser
la manade de basile boli par exemple je
sais c'est ça ce reçu 6 1
si je crois c'est signe du cerveau donc
puis sûreté a
devant les joueurs ils ont des camions
avec des vitres teintées mener quand
j'ai les bras qui adore comme les
princes arabes des gens les reconnaître
à travers
oui bonsoir bonsoir c'est ça me les
toupies de bacardi et pascal praud au
quatrième s'il vous plaît priez
mais tu rentraient bien dans les boîtes
de nuit quand même aller vers agen pour
l'histoire des bagnoles belge est faux
dans le temps avec les compteurs geiger
une deux chevaux ou une cacho il va les
regarder on avait le kilométrage bon
rien la dre théâtre direct mirettes
ça rigole pas en classe
[Musique]
dans ce temps là y'avait pas de boîte il
allait au bal et il y avait un orchestre
cave et la quote part par département
c'était alma 0,5 dans l'yonne
pas difficile oui mais moi je travaille
toujours la presse donc je regardais
dans le journal où étaient alma 0,5
alors il était à saint florentin alors
je passais le soir vers huit heures je
connais les numéros les compteurs des
joueurs amis joueurs susceptibles de
sortir
son choix
et puis je repassais à 7 heures du matin
il y avait 54 km de plus donc il avait
été à saint florentin les canadiens
qui arrivait en face et on vous
attendait des jumeaux qui joue chez nous
c'est important la guerre sont dix ans
aussi capitale vous allez composé des
entraînements sa 101 minutes et tout est
si le mec il va en boîte jusqu'à 4h mais
vous êtes le vrai imbécile d'avoir fait
des entraînements avant tout est détruit
sa mère de base y compris
allez-y
je disais une double en soirée en
discothèque égale des machos
il
faudra passer à table que sa pensée
les jeunes chez nous au attend attend
avant d'aller attaque on va on va goûter
ça quand même
samuel eto'o que l'un des plus grands
joueurs africains il a débarqué un jour
au havre à 14 ans il n'avait pas de
papiers pièce qu'il a repéré à l'époque
personne après si je ne me trompe pas il
est parti ensuite il n'avait pas de
papiers il est parti au galop martinon
real madrid il reparti au gabon au
cameroun après je n'avais pas de papiers
obligé de cacher tout ça n'avait pas de
papiers je suis resté anti que moi c'est
moi et j'étais chez ma grossesse je vois
pas ça c'est parce que c'était l'époque
où il y avait ce problème de papiers en
france et la télé star il fait remarquer
18 18 buts en 19 matchs ou un truc du
sud deux buts à un dessin format de l'an
prochain été ballon d'or tu sais pas non
mais
on passe à table
[Musique]
côté au toit
le problème c'est ce que n'est en un
côté j mon problème c'est ce que des
papiers soient bouche comme je pense que
tire et aux bouffes placard et la
rockstar
games non c'est une belle et les bals
bidon
la
salle est belle
samuel oui j'arrive tout cela vient de
voler la voiture c'est toi chérie
[Musique]
l'aml commun ça commence à vous ce type
de bentley de
300 un peu plus
tu as tu touches comme m j'ai bien à
barcelone
excuse moi je vais faire le mec il est
arrivé c'était un sans papier il avait
même pas le droit de jouer au ballon ah
oui il est très bon il est très bien
tellement même voiture alors
il faut compter
à peu près aller à 2,16 un
gage des garagistes alors tu joues pas à
barcelone les garagistes
vous savez quand même temps tu gagnes de
l'argent
dix ans quand tu arrives au bar sert
quand avez-vous quand nous quand tu
arrives à l'entrée du stade parce qu'une
fois j'ai été le voir quand avait il dit
c'est simple ça mais elle est aussi
celui qui a le plus grand parking
de l'équipe du barça mais quel âge tu as
24 ans troque
comment ça vaut par exemple de si
quelqu'un veut acheter samuel eto'o mais
dont j'ai un club si cher je veux jouer
des jeux veut l'engager comme ça me
coûte
combien milliards c'est beaucoup
d'absents millions d'euros 150 millions
150 millions d'orange a plus le salaire
milliard un milliard a mêlé à un
milliard de francs non de nouveau oui il
vaut cher le gardasil boscher le maire
est nommé de l'eau un milliard de
nouveaux clients il est très bon il est
il est leader il est leader des buteurs
du championnat d'espagne
non mais attends moi je sais qui c'est
minable
non mais déjà tu as le transfert que tu
rachètes mais après il faut aussi lui
payer son salaire tous les mois mais il
faut que tu lui réparé la voiture
kerbala hellfest voiture quand on est
petit problème c'est quand même énorme
en ouvrant des plus content lâche toi
[Musique]
moi je pense arrêter à 32 ans et à
laquelle je vais faire un prêt à les
jouer à mayol
habitat bailleur mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui vous ont fait majorque et
tous et si fabuleux que ça que je suis
arrivé en europe j'ai connu beaucoup de
problèmes quand je suis arrivé au real
madrid il y avait médias tové davos au
caire là où tous et des stars c'était
difficile pour moi de jouer j'étais
jeune de 14 ans dont je jouais avec la
deuxième équipe mais je pouvais joueurs
ah oui j'ai fait mon problème est à 16
ans avec l'oréal
et bien après j'ai connu beaucoup de
problèmes avec le président tout ça je
suis parti à mayotte et à maillot que je
suis connu le bonheur des heureux j
jeudi j'ai un avocat depuis bientôt six
ans si cet abus des gens non je
n'évoquerai pilonnages ont mais nous
n'en avons créés répondent pas pour ça
que j'y prends des rois il prend des
fils d un succès au jeune les honoraires
mais tu n'as plus besoin d'agents
aujourd'hui pas besoin d'argent mais si
tu veux aussi réussi l'épreuve
c'est une question de se placer c'est
bien parce que les des jeunes
footballeurs aujourd'hui il ya ceux qui
sont moins qu'ils pensent peut-être
cannes et en argent ils seront peut-être
mais c'est pas si l'entrée parce que si
tu es fort il n'y a pas une loi qui ils
ont à [__] qu'il faut voir un agent
sous
sas et c'est plutôt bien je veux dire
tous mes grands joueurs à auxerre vous
avez pas tu n'as pas été très gentils
sur le ballon d'or en disant que je
trouvais pas le ballon d'or de france
football tu trouvais qu'on avait
peut-être mal noté que que tu m'avais
être mieux classé que sa question est la
suivante pour ça je te pose la question
parce que sur la suivante
comment vous faites pour noter les
joueurs et remettre le prix au joueur
qui gagne normalement assez suit les
forts de l'année alors dites-moi savoir
qui était mayer qui est tôt durant
l'année coûte c'est bien ça oui vous
allez ça commence le premier je te
rejoins je te rejoins tabac dans
apprécié de la juge ronis est un joueur
exceptionnel et je suis heureux parce
qu'il a gagné mais si c'est l'année jeu
non mais de toute façon ça mais après
c'est que choisir
non mais je te fais pas de souci
pascal la france au mondial mais la
france et va se balader quand tu as
vieira trezeguet et durable dans sa
colonne vertébrale qui sont la colonne
vertébrale de la juve aujourd'hui tu vas
faire un bon mondial
simplement on est passé d'un excès à
l'autre on était tellement optimiste il
ya quatre ans où il ya six ans on pense
à les reprendre la coupe du monde cette
phase i en verve dans l'autre sens
relève au mieux de la vieja très déçu g
dans un axe situera lavieu thuram non
mais
21h59 basile boli quand il jouait à
auxerre si tu m'as anelka en attaque où
dany ils vont le mettre en quatre
suspects restaient
210 on passe à autre chose et tu peux
peut-être influencé un petit peu pour
qu'anelka swan on
s'est fait lancer et eut perdu
l'influencé mention sur la chaîne un
canapé franchement c'est moi qui vais
choisir sa sueur
comme aux grands de quelques secrets de
sélection tu sais
quand toi tu discutes avec ta femme qui
parle de choses et tout et on parle pas
de football non mais tu es aussi mais
nous on parle quand on parle du métier
on parle de joueurs qu'on connaît tous
les deux et je veux dire j'ai reçu un
appel sur le plateau était comme ci
comme ça on va en parler on parle de
gens qu'on connaît tous les deux comme
et comme ta femme tu pas tu parles de
toujours que vous le sexe avec sa
famille
que pour une coupe du monde c'est très
très bien d'avoir deux gardiens de
grande qualité comme fabien barthez et
grégory coupet qui en avait en 98 il y
en avait mais il ya eu un gros problème
avec barthez non il ya un problème c'est
qu'il y avait là madame a refusé d'être
numéro deux parce que le problème il est
là c'est que le sélectionneur va un
moment donné de voir désigner qui de
coupet ou de barthez est numéro 1 ouais
il faut que l'otan soit deux niveaux g
il faut que celui qui accepte qui va
être numéro 2 accepte d'être numérique
ou pays n'accepterait tu crois je pense
que grégory coupet acceptant avec plus
d'être numéro de la marque que barachet
martèle ce barrage
maryse et ben moi je pense barthez c'est
un bon mec moi je pense que dans la tête
de raymond domenech il ya longtemps que
c'est décidé je pense que c'est depuis
très longtemps grégory coupet si tu
verrais qui nettoie pas langue de bois
si il faut choisir ah non c'est moi je
suis tu sélectionnes je suis plus coupé
que cabardès d'accord qui tu mettrais
d'autres donc on a vu les gaules y en a
deux disons qu'on voit les défenseurs ça
va tout seul aussi un tuyau à mettre un
terrain qui tue mais à gauche alors ça
va elle trouvait depuis que lizarazu n'a
pu hélas est un problème à l'équipe de
france a les banques à gauche et bon y'a
que y'a que
15% de gauche et dans la population la
nature et qui dit toi que me latéral
gauche ce serial kangala s'ils jouent
ils un peu emmerdé quand il doit centrer
du gauche plein il aime pas je voulais
d'ailleurs un web est d'accord mais dans
le meilleur club du monde il y joue
quand même donc c'est un featuring
alignement dernière mieux terrain guy ça
c'est une feria vieira forcément
s'il à son niveau et devrait devant un
même trop un peu et l'appareil honorer
un peu trop
dans les possibles attaquant de pointe
il y à peu et gay henry cissé anelka
ça ça
l'est de tous les temps cit avait cinq
joueurs à classer dans l'ordre tu
mettrais qui en premier jusqu'au
cinquième projet - roger milla non ça
dans l'autre roger d'accord moi j'étais
jeune et je vu j'ai vu rouge et faire
des choses que je me suis dit ce mec je
pleure car en tant que ça à phénomène
c'est un phénomène lemarchal bureau de
du mot de maradona ça s'est
désolé tranche a nié avoir cautionné
j'ai pas vu pellet pour moi c'est le
nombril et je parle parlons pas de ceux
qui jouent actuellement parce que ça
serait difficile mais ceux qui ont ce
qu'ils ont arrêtés pelé maradona cruyff
platini zidane le talent peu les épaules
et ses miroirs inovallée nom peut
laisser dieu s'égaliser
platini ou zidane comme emplettes 'new
deal' l'appareil
mais oui pareil à des époques
différentes avec des qualités de
légèrement différent à thierry platini
je faisais mes parts et je connais par
coeur c'est signé platini ou zidane
platini alors mois plus tôt platini oui
mais mais en étant en étant en disant
que si l'équipe de france
version platine y avait eu la chance de
disputer une coupe du monde en france il
aurait gagné d'une heure mais d'une
heure il aurait gagné maintenant c'était
la ligne droite de longchamp
moi je voulais devenir footballeur c'est
mon rêve j'ai vu roger milla j'ai cru je
me suis dit je veux ressembler à ce mec
tu as dit il n'ya pas longtemps tu as
dit ils veulent être eto'o ou d'autres
joueurs africains qui symbolise non pas
pour non pas pour être et tout mais pour
gagner des millions non seulement les
jeunes africains il ya tellement de
joueurs africains les jeunes européens
au jeudi quand ils arrivent ils vont
voir la belle bagnole de cervélo d'un
autre footballeur il ne pense pas s'il
ya un travail mais est ce que tu es ya
le travail égal parce que les gens ce
que permet ce qu'on perçoit pas c'est
que c'est un génie certes à des milliers
de fou cette endémie lieu la différence
viendra comme lui et les gens pensent en
l'écoutant que c'est facile et ça serait
une erreur faites-le être champions
olympiques en escrime c'est facile ils
sont sans être champion du monde en
football c'est impossible tellement qu
elle ça non mais
janot mais ça va
être le meilleur footballeur de sa
génération c'est un génie sur la masse
totale en jeu bien qu'il parle d'un
talent
déjà avec mais qu'est ce que m mais
qu'est ce que tu as envie de ce que
c'est il ya comme un côté scandale tous
ces jeunes joueurs africains qui ont
fait miroiter des trucs donc ça c'est
autre chose les agents non mais c'est
important parce qu'on attend c'est bien
tu
as raison mais tiens y'a un film moi que
j'ai trouvé scandaleux ces points
qu'elles marquent de godasses dumas il
raconte des
trucs et bizarre quand même tu vois est
ce que toi tu es contre ça et tu te
tournes ce truc là qu'ils cautionnent le
fait qu'on fait croire à des jeunes
africains qui peuvent débarquer en
europe et gagner des millions qu'ils
peuvent débarquer dans le secteur dont
le but est là mais le rêve dans cette
publicité il faut révéler si tu veux des
venues samuel eto'o il faut rêver moi je
rêve toujours le rêve de gagner la
champion's league au japon bien gérald
jean n'ai pas vu moi ce gamin de gamins
perdus on a fait des articles de
journaux on a fait des additions
juillet des agents qui tourne autour de
combien aujourd'hui mais la vie
l'afrique il n'y a pas d'avenir en
afrique pourquoi n'y a pas d'avenir
m'apprit cap al anon
millions déjà ici on vous présente comme
un boulet guerre
- donné la frigoule vieux c'est urgent
neurones ceibal aucun nom mais je veux
qu'on a c'est magnifique le cameroun
il ya des gens qui sont préparés là bas
mais seulement ya pas de boulot tu fais
tes études tu fais tout tu n'as rien à
faire
tu n'as rien à faire mais moi je savais
que j'avais des moyens pour devenir
footballeur mais il faut se sacrifier
je ne bois pas je fus un milieu pauvre
même cause oui mais ma maman et s'élève
à 3 heures du matin pour aller acheter
le poisson et revendre au marché du
comment ça s'est passé samuel quand tu
étais petit comment tu as compris ça
comment ça s'est passé non moi et déjà
j'avais on est en forme un groupe notion
12 et g8 qui vivent avec moi
bon on avait pris une décision celui qui
réussit sur la maison la famille non non
j'ai dû jouer un copain d'accord celui
qui devait réussite devait prendre les
autres et appartenant footballeur ceux
qui travaillent à l'aéroport mais on
était tellement organisé quand on se
retrouvait le soir toi qui allait jouer
au football tu avais 500 francs cfa ça
représente rien euros celui qui quitte à
l'aéropot qui accompagnait elle essaie
de les étrangers qui arrivait découvrez
un peu le cameroun y gagne un peu plus
dont se retrouvait en partager tout ça
assez drôle c'est jouer j'ai joué j'ai
eu la chance j'ai connu de monsieur et
qui m'ont amené à avignon à un tournoi
et à notre retour en repartent au
cameroun j'étais à notre-dame souvent je
passe devant je dis ne disent pas réussi
on était à la rue ce malade et prenez
des photos j'ai disparu
je me retrouve à paris et c'était
l'époque où les papiers on attrape tu
repars
je suis jeune à mon âge je pouvais plus
aller à l'école je pouvais plus jouer au
football je me suis retrouvé là sept
mois rien faire
le plus important pour moi c'est pas
l'argent j'ai réussi aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance de voir une devant ma famille je
prépare l'après football mais c'est
d'aider les autres et c'est ce qui me
fait plus plaisir aujourd'hui donc je
dis pas je calcule pas quand je suis
face à un problème je calcule pas si le
mec est réellement dans le besoin je
sors mon agent et c'est ça le plus
important et ça c'est ma fierté c'est
moi souvent je me retrouve dans une
prison et tu vois un jeune qui a 9 ans
il n'a pas fait 7000 francs cfa ça
représente quoi
a340
il passe deux ans aux usa parce qu'il a
volé un portable en main présent chez
nos patients pick portable il passe deux
ans tu vois dans ses yeux qui n'a rien
qui n'as rien tu sais quand il sort de
là à oui mais il devient un bras cassé
il devient pro et ça c'est complètement
vrai il faut éviter ça et il faut éviter
ça et éviter ça c'est quoi c'est que
aujourd'hui
j'ai ma notoriété qui me permet de
rencontrer plusieurs personnes qui
veulent bien m'aider mais il met pas ce
que c'est moi
donc je vais voir un procureur j'ai dit
il ya tel jeunes tels de tenue d'un tel
prison
papaye je ne peux pas je me dis mais
après tu fais quoi c'est mon problème je
disais qu'après le jeu ni il est dedans
je fais quoi lui
donne l'argent tu donnes la rejoint mais
il fait rien il faut créer faut créer
mais seul je peux pas la demande auprès
de lui elle doit être sans fin tu dois
être confrontés beaucoup de demandes
jusqu'à présent c'est pas sympa même si
je mets un million d'euros 1 million
d'euros à l'afrique s'y sont des
millions ça fait 6 à la hausse iliad
pourquoi tu veux tester les meilleurs
que pourquoi tu veux pas retourner au
cameroun pour t'occuper de ton pays
parce que je peux plus vivre aujourd'hui
aucun - pourquoi j'ai plus de vie moi
quand je suis au cameroun ternie judo 3
heures
je sors avec mes copains on revient à 5h
à 6h moi c'est comme ça il faut que je
m'entraîne ça c'est mon entraînement
perso quand je m'entraîne je suis
tranquille je reviens j'ai mes trucs à
faire je passe dix jours au cameroun je
reçois les gens tout en tout temps tout
le temps même dans ma bagnole et je
marche parfois avec trois cent mille
euros en liquide
tu sais ce que vous êtes arrêté en
quarts au four
tu vois les gens enfin tu vois dans les
yeux ils ont fait interviewer tu bosses
tu peux pas parfois j'ai dit jules dakar
même
des billets au mono je pense que nous en
fait on est en mission c'est pas ça fait
un peu histoire c'est l'histoire de
filmer à un moment donné on est en
mission
comme je disais on a la chance de défier
de voyager tout va dès qu'on peut donner
comme c'est dit et nous si on peut
donner notre cachet
pour pour les jeunes ont fait on en a
fait on va faire on va faire des
concerts on va faire des concerts
gratuits pour les mettre en prison
nous dire qu'on a fait on a fait une
tournée de quarante dates avant la
sortie de l'album en mjc tu vois gratuit
donc c'est ça faut donner je pense quand
il a dit c'est ça qui donne à ton
prochain sait pas
si les africains avaient la mentalité
que nous avons nous
90% mouraient de faim et les 10 % les
regarderai nourrir alors ils survivent
tous parce qu'ils partagent alors s'ils
partagent pas de manière égale ce qu'on
le pouvoir et prennent un peu plus mais
quand même y partage y partagent ils
partagent et nouveau partage pas voilà
est-ce que je tiens à dire c'est que
je trouve que c'est bien ce que tu fais
par rapport à parce que malheureusement
on n'a pas la possibilité de passer
d'avoir d'avoir un gros support
médiatique est nombreux à nombreuses
reprises quand je regarde ton émission
je vois qu'à des rappeurs il ya un
bâtard est arrêté
ntm iam j'habitais fieschi cff 600 booba
stomisés kery james et sauf que ça c'est
bien elle malheureusement il n'ya pas
bouille a pas beaucoup de gens comme ça
qui nous donne une tribu une tribune
pour pouvoir développer notre musique
pour pouvoir montrer aux gens que le rap
c'est pas c'est pas juste des mecs des
deux mondes venture durak commenté sur
deux chez les
chats les rats black music ok mais chez
marcel cd sheng eto'o c'est l'échec et
on a pas on a pas on n'a pas souvent
l'occasion de montrer que les mecs de
rap c'est pas des mecs avec des
casquettes à la délation ces démissions
en série qui ont une sensibilité c'est
le mec qui ont des choses à dire c'est
les mecs qui ont des histoires c'est la
poésie de agouazi et
oui bonsoir ou bonjour que jeune
saccomano au quatrième étage monsieur je
suis vous plaire
[Musique]
monsieur bonsoir
fermement
en iran
un valet moi je travaille et je vais pas
rentrer était joyeux comme toi tu
attends sl allez venez dans mon émission
les mêmes début elle était formidable l
effort des navy seals menacé sa
démission n'est pas toujours
qu'elles
pensent qu'on l'a copié les attaques
d'ailleurs j'ai un message de bernard
tapie pour la soirée voilà appelé ce
matin mais on m'a dit qu'il est amoureux
de cécile simeone ah oui il me l'a dit
aussi c'est pas vrai il a dit 25 mille
fois qu'il avait une seule femme dans sa
vie mais vous êtes ensemble dans le film
d'anne non non je suis un psy flics non
non je suis en permanence mais
mademoiselle mademoiselle simeone dans
une commissaire valence est excellente
je tiens à le dire il appelle à très
éprouvé par la faire aider il a été très
éprouvé le premier jour oui mais là lire
dans l'émission il avait lu formidable à
mascate formidable et il aurait même
sport gondi serait durer deux jours
ouais mais j attends à ce que cette vie
non mais dis donc la seule chose vraie
qui reste on a fait une piqûre dans la
fesse deadly avant le match peut-être de
vitamine c intra intramusculaire après
il dit à valenciennes 1 valenciennes
tout le monde le sait il ya eu un procès
il ya un verdict bon alors on sait qui a
fait quoi enfin faut toujours croire la
justice du point
la justice met fin à faire après et bien
après y'a plus rien alors hier y passe
moi j'ai veillé à j'étais fatigué pour
ses doigts et dit pourquoi vous ai dis
ça je dis ça pour moi parce que j'ai
besoin de ça on comprend mais besoin
d'eux alors qu'est-ce qu'il a ajouté de
nouveaux il y avait des champs et
desailly qu'est-ce que ceux qui étaient
sur le bateau il était il avait un
patron le patron leur a dit vous venez
sur le bateau sur une bateau après
est-ce qu'ils étaient compromis dans la
course dans l'histoire de vernon le
procédé a jamais mis dedans alors c'est
tout il a rien dit
moi je pense à
toi tu n'as tu n'as que des amis autour
de cette table et moi il ya cécile
simeone qui depuis qu'on lui parle de
toi si tu veux aller transfiguré
elle tu adores ces cas une grosse
ouverture est
ce que tu connais samuel eto'o
bon je vais te le passé je vais te le
passé il veut le faire signer à l'om et
l'ol est à la star des scénarios dit la
star des stars de dallas
n'ont pas les épaules
une saison marseille
ok je vous attends mais pas 40 ans
merci je ferai de mon mieux
je vous ai pas téléphoné parce qu'il n'y
avait pas lieu et quand vous avez appelé
j'étais en train de dire s'il avait
passé une semaine à saint barth comme y
passe d'habitude personne en aurait
parlé parce que y'a rien y ait eu
ou et non il n'ya rien ils en ont rien
fait voilà moi j'ai regardé alors que
j'étais malade hier soir j'ai regardé
fogiel
tu as regardé feu très doux je dis ça
chez terry hardy seul à te dire la cote
que
bon j'ai quand même voulu voir et demi
il avait rien à dire
finalement je retiens une chose c'est
que ce jour là il a plus de piqûres dans
les fesses s'il l'a dit ça doit être
vrai une intramusculaire de
je-ne-sais-quoi peut-être d'eau
distillée et puis ça l'a fait courir
lille a dit que les hôtes en avait pris
ils ont tous dit qu'ils en avaient pas
pris donc il reste rien il me reste rien
mais non vas tu sais tout restera pour
secret entre
nous sera malheureux il est tellement
gentil mon gardien de but
gros bisous thierry rolland l'appareil
samuel regrette beaucoup de ne pas avoir
joué à l'om de la grande époque
sinon t'as pas osé venir signer la non
arrivée en italie pour n'a pas osé
brésil et qui fournit peu de jeu falloir
de le dire
moi qui fais donc un jour maman une cure
de jouvence
il est à médrano
merano
demande ce que je fais donc je vais
expliquer ce que je faisais avec bernard
le commissaire valence permanente et que
je bossais sur l'ol tv donc prochaine de
l'olympique lyonnais que je faisais des
émissions où on la voit à chaque fois où
on va lyon cauchemar en avant un match
je
fais deux les émissions j'emmène les
joueurs faire autre chose on les
retrouve dans d'autres situations pour
les connaître un peu mieux on parle de
tout et tous
voilà
sur les joueurs de maison maintenant des
trucs très clean et où on peut parler un
peu d'autres choses on parle pas du tout
de foot
[Musique]
m
oui bonsoir soir
au quatrième étage s'il vous plaît aux
caisses et jacky callebaut et moi même
[Musique]
je ne sais pas à quoi m'attendre
et civilisé
messieurs bonsoir monsieur bonsoir
jd power
c'est en jeu fait cher le
charme et sedar
alors je vais vous avouer pourquoi je ne
mets pas le bonnet d'auxerre pour deux
raisons la première c'est que je suis
neutre je commande des concurrents
d'auxerre dont je suis ne trompait pas
c'est quand j'ai le bonnet d'auxerre
tout le monde me le réclament au bout de
cinq minutes je ne l'est plus donc j'ai
perdu un bonnet et j'ai froid
sont un peu plus haut
c'est ça l'histoire fait remarquer guy
rouge à l'époque des kleenex il ya
toujours un mouchoir en tissu
comme ça tu peux l'avait
bien sûr je vais pas le jeter si je sais
que ça fait trois trucs main
premièrement premièrement on a battu une
forêt pour les faire
deuxièmement
je vais les jeter et troisièmement et
vont constituer une pollution voilà donc
ces trois défauts successifs tandis que
mon mouchoir cat est fait à partir de
lait cultivés dans les champs si les
gars première mort a fait a permis à des
paysans de vivre deuxièmement
investissent rang et troisièmement des
lavandières voilà tu les gardes combien
de temps tu es mouchoirs bas jusqu'à ce
que je dis merde ou que je les donne à
des dates bien
combien il est affreux
c'est un couple de belges qui se
connaissent pas et c'est en plein été et
ils font l'ascension d'une paroi
rocheuse dans le massif du mont blanc
alors il grimpe et il arrive au sommet
ils se connaissent toujours pas ce qui
sera une cordée mais l'un en dessous de
l'autre et il marche comme il est 10
heures du soir ils peuvent pas
redescendre vers la vallée il marche
vers le refuge et puis y en a un qui dit
alors tu dis oh ben tu es d'où toi dis
moi je suis de bruxelles on me dit moi
je suis de lier et j'ai tout peut-être
pourrions-nous passé la soirée avec
plaisir et tout et ils marchent ils
arrivèrent le directeur du refuge et 10
nous voudrions une chambre double s'il
vous plaît
s'il vous dit on est en plein été là il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de bons dire est
que tout des chambres individuelles
mais avec un petit lit si vous mettez en
tête bêche et tout ça bon bien que
qu'est ce que tu en penses toi lui dit
momo moi d'accord et tout bon mais il
dit c'est entendu pas trop nous
l'apprenons bon point de la chambre ils
vont ils vont dîner et puis vers 11
heures du soir bon ben on va aller se
coucher maintenant me dit c'est entendu
allons nous coucher alors il arrive oui
profit ce maître tête bêche puis au bout
de deux minutes y en a un qui dit à
l'autre dit ça ne va pas du tout il dit
qu'est ce qui à mes 10 gt pied dans la
gueule là ça sent terriblement me dit je
vais te dire la même chose pour une nuit
mettons nous ensemble côte à côte bd oui
oui très bien mes propres il se met côte
à côte
et
au bout de deux minutes il ya le même
qui disent ça ne va pas du tout il dit
qu'est ce qui a obligé oublié de vous
dire que quand je suis en altitude comme
ça au delà de 1800 mètres avant de
m'endormir il faut toujours que je me
masturbe un petit peu il ya le deuxième
idée dit oui disent aussi bien il dit
mais vous pourriez prendre la vôtre tout
de même
à piston qui demande à son père papa tu
connais la différence entre peux tu
m'expliquer la différence entre
potentiellement est réellement donc le
père il appelle sa femme heidi chéri
bien voir si richard geere de proposé de
coucher avec toi pour un million d'euros
accepterais tu
chéris richard geere un million d'euros
ont vu les problèmes qu'on a en ce
moment je pense que j'accepterai bon son
mari lui dis ok il appelle sa fille dit
ma fille chérie vient voir papa
ma fille chérie si brad pitt eux proposé
de coucher avec toi pour un million
d'euros acceptant accepterais tu papa
brad pitt un million d'euros je pense
que j'accepterai et là le père il se
retourne vers son fils il lui dit tu
vois à fiston potentiellement on a deux
millions d'euros à la maison mais
réellement on a deux [__]
vient enflammer la piste de danse vient
ya du bon son et de l'ambiance vient
bouger dans tous les sens vient tout est
permis non pas d'interdît vient
enflammer la piste de danse vient ya du
bon son et de l'ambiance vient bouger
dans tous les sens vient tout est permis
vient pas d'un ter ce soir tout est
permis donc vas-y on peut y aller que
des vip dont personne n'est recalés ça
se bouscule à l'entrée à l'intérieur ça
se déchaîne tout le monde clap clap clap
c'est le dden sur le phénomène ça bouge
ça danse voilà le sens à l aimait déjà
se mêlent deux roues bouge encore
ce parti vient enflammer la piste d'êta
y a du bon sens et de l' ambiance bien
bouger dans tous les bien toutes les
paires n'y a pas d'interdît enflammer la
piste de danse
y a du bon sens et en riant
bouger dans tous les sens tout est
permis ce soir tout est permis d'en face
on peut y aller
et puis donc personne est recalé ça se
bouscule à l'entrée à l'intérieur sa
fraîcheur tout le monde c'est le deuil
son traîneau mais là ça bouge ça berce
dans la boîte ça transpire vasicek ungur
l'isf et nos plaisirs de l'eau la
nouvelle dans ce nouveau style mais
comme tout est permis à pas d'attitude
chez
toi le lagon
la lega groupe
pour
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux